سأعلمكم عن كرة تدور لكنها ليست كرة وهي لا تدور اليوم في Qiskit في
الفصل الدراسي سنتحدث عن هذه الخاصية الكمية المسماة اللف المغزلي بالنظر إلى التجربة التي وجدت أول دليل عليها
مرحباً بكم في Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي في هذه السلسلة سنستخدم Qiskit لاستكشاف بعض المفاهيم الأساسية التي تُغطى عادةً
في المقررات المتعلقة بالحوسبة الكمية كل فيديو سيكون مصحوباً أيضاً بوحدة تفاعلية
مرتبطة في الوصف أدناه فتأكدوا من الاطلاع عليها اليوم نتحدث عن تجربة Stern-Gerlach عام 1922
وهي واحدة من أشهر التجارب في تاريخ النظرية الكمية لأنها تُظهر بوضوح كيف يعمل اللف
المغزلي الكمي لكن هذا لم يكن ما قصد Stern أو Gerlach إظهاره صُممت التجربة لاختبار نموذج كمي جديد
للذرة يُسمى نموذج Bohr على اسم Niels Bohr الذي اقترحه عام 1913 في النموذج كانت الإلكترونات تدور حول
النواة في مدارات منفصلة ويمكنها الانتقال بين تلك المدارات عن طريق امتصاص أو إصدار
فوتونات كل مدار كان له زخم زاوي مُكمَّم يكون مضاعفاً صحيحاً لثابت أساسي صغير
يُسمى h بار في العقد الثاني ومطلع العشرينات كانت ميكانيكا الكم جديدة تماماً جديدة لدرجة
أنها لم تكن تُسمى ميكانيكا الكم بعد فلم يكن الجميع مقتنعاً بنموذج Bohr فيزيائي
اسمه Otto Stern كرهه ووصف النموذج بالهراء وذهب لحد التهديد بترك الفيزياء إن ثبتت صحة Bohr
كان Stern مصمماً جداً على إثبات خطأ النموذج فتوصل إلى طريقة عبقرية لاختباره و
استعان بـ Walther Gerlach لمساعدته في تصميم وإجراء التجربة اتضح أنه لم يثبت خطأ Bohr بل
أثبت خطأ نفسه كانت تجربتهما بسيطة جداً ونتائجها صارخة لدرجة أنها حسمت
الجدل تقريباً ميكانيكا الكم تحكم على المستوى الذري لم يدركا ذلك في حينه
لكن تجربة Stern و Gerlach وجدت أيضاً دليلاً قاطعاً على اللف المغزلي الذاتي للإلكترون وهو
خاصية أساسية جديدة للطبيعة ضرورية لتفسير المغناطيسية والموصلية الفائقة وكثير من
الكيمياء اليوم سأشرح لكم كيف تعمل تجربة Stern-Gerlach وما نتوقع رؤيته كلاسيكياً
من التجربة وما وجده Stern و Gerlach فعلاً ثم سأريكم كيف يمكنكم إجراء تجربة
من نوع Stern-Gerlach مع Qiskit وحاسوب IBM الكمي الفكرة الأساسية لتجربة
Stern-Gerlach كانت إيجاد طريقة لتحديد ما إذا كان الزخم الزاوي لإلكترون في ذرة مُكمَّماً كما
تنبأ Bohr أم لا كما توقع Stern استخدموا حقيقة أن الزخم الزاوي للإلكترون سيتسبب أيضاً في وجود
حقل مغناطيسي صغير حول كل ذرة يمكنكم التفكير بها كمغانط قضيبية
صغيرة بدت التجربة هكذا كان هناك فرن مليء بذرات
الفضة وحقل مغناطيسي بالقطبين الشمالي والجنوبي
هنا الحقل كان أقوى بالقرب من الأعلى وأضعف بالقرب من الأسفل فأنتج تدرجاً يشير لأعلى
وأخيراً كانت هناك شاشة في التجربة الفرن سخّن ذرات الفضة حتى تبخرت ثم
انطلقت من الفرن مع اتجاه المغناطيس القضيبي الصغير لكل ذرة عشوائي تماماً ثم مرت الذرات
عبر الحقل المغناطيسي فدُفعت الذرات لأعلى أو لأسفل بقوة تعتمد على اتجاه
القطب الشمالي لكل ذرة بالنسبة لتدرج الحقل ثم اصطدمت الذرات بالشاشة يستطيع Stern و Gerlach النظر
إلى أين اصطدمت الذرات على الشاشة لمعرفة شيء عن الزخم الزاوي للإلكترونات توقع Stern أن الذرات
في التجربة ستتصرف كما كنت أصفها حتى الآن كمغانط قضيبية صغيرة تطيع
قواعد الفيزياء الكلاسيكية كلاسيكياً هذه المغانط الذرية الصغيرة يمكن أن تتجه في أي اتجاه عشوائي وعندما
تعبر الحقل المغناطيسي ستتعرض لمجموعة من القوى المختلفة التي تدفعها لأعلى أو لأسفل حسب تلك الاتجاهات مغناطيس
يشير في نفس اتجاه التدرج سيتعرض لقوة كبيرة لأعلى وفي الاتجاه المعاكس
سيتعرض لقوة كبيرة لأسفل وإذا كان في مكان بينهما ستكون القوة أضعف إذا كان المغناطيس الذري يشير
عمودياً على التدرج فلن يتعرض لأي قوة وسيستمر في خط مستقيم بسبب هذا
المدى من القوى الممكنة يجب أن تصطدم جميع الذرات بالشاشة في نقاط عمودية مختلفة النمط الذي ستصنعه
على الشاشة سيبدو شيئاً كهذا لكن هذا ليس كل ما رآه Stern و
Gerlach بل رأوا بقعتين منفصلتين تماماً من الذرات على الشاشة بدون أي ذرات في
المنتصف لم تكن لديهم النظرية الصحيحة في ذلك الوقت لتفسير هذا لكننا نعلم الآن أنهم رأوا هذا لأن
كل إلكترون لديه مقدار من الزخم الزاوي الذاتي على شكل لف مغزلي لا يمكن أن يأخذ إلا واحدة
من قيمتين في صورة المغناطيس القضيبي هذا يعني أنه لا يوجد سوى اتجاهين مسموحين لمغانط الذرات نسمي
هذين الاتجاهين لف مغزلي لأعلى ولف مغزلي لأسفل الـ qubit في حاسوب كمي
يشبه هذا النوع من أنظمة اللف المغزلي وبعض الحواسيب الكمية تستخدم فعلاً qubit مصنوعة من حالات اللف المغزلي
للإلكترون فيمكننا إجراء تجربة Stern-Gerlach خاصة بنا مع Qiskit والـ qubit في حاسوب IBM الكمي لنربط
حالة اللف المغزلي لأعلى للإلكترون بحالة الصفر للـ qubit وحالة اللف المغزلي لأسفل بحالة الواحد
على الـ qubit عندما خرجت جسيمات الفضة من الفرن كانت عزومها المغناطيسية عشوائية الاتجاه يمكننا
نمذجة تجربة Stern-Gerlach بإنشاء circuit كمية بسيطة مع qubit واحد يبدأ في حالة
الصفر هذا يُسمى مخطط circuit حيث السلك العلوي هو الـ qubit والعمليات المطبقة على الـ qubit
تظهر كمربعات على السلك مربعا RX و RZ هما gate كمية
تدير فعلياً الاتجاه المغناطيسي للذرة يمكننا اختيار قيم عشوائية لـ theta و phi هنا لتدوير
الـ qubit بمقدار عشوائي وهذا يحاكي الفرن الذي يُخرج الذرات باتجاهات لف مغزلي عشوائية المربع الرمادي هو
قياسنا يخبرنا إن كان الـ qubit في حالة صفر أو واحد ويرسل ذلك القياس إلى بت كلاسيكي
الخط المزدوج المسمى c هذا الجزء مكافئ لقياس ما إذا كانت الذرة في لف مغزلي لأعلى أو لأسفل بالنظر إلى
أي بقعة تصطدم بها على الشاشة يمكننا استخدام أداة Qiskit الأساسية المسماة sampler لتشغيل التجربة عدة مرات كل منها بقيم
عشوائية مختلفة لـ theta و phi بعد 100 عينة نحصل على مدرج تكراري للقياسات يبدو هكذا حوالي
50% من الوقت يُقاس الـ qubit ليكون صفراً و50% من الوقت يكون في حالة 1 هذه نفس نتيجة Stern
و Gerlach دائماً إما لف مغزلي لأعلى أو لأسفل ولا شيء بينهما عند هذه النقطة قد تفكرون حسناً
بالطبع حصلنا على نتيجتين منفصلتين أجرينا التجربة على حاسوب كمي رقمي يُرجع دائماً فقط
صفر أو واحد وهذا صحيح لكن تذكروا أن السبب الكامل وراء أن الحواسيب الكمية تُرجع نتائج ثنائية وفي الحقيقة
السبب وراء عمل الحوسبة الكمية أصلاً هو بالضبط تكميم اللف المغزلي الذي اكتشفه Stern و Gerlach أولاً
الـ qubit في حواسيب IBM الكمية ليست مبنية على اللف المغزلي لكن حواسيب كمية كثيرة أخرى كذلك فإجراء
تجربة Stern-Gerlach على حاسوب كمي يسمح لنا فعلاً بإعادة اكتشاف تكميم اللف المغزلي
منذ عام 1922 أُجريت توسعات لا تُحصى للتجربة الأصلية لـ Stern-Gerlach هذه التوسعات تتضمن
إرسال نفس حزمة الذرات عبر أجهزة Stern-Gerlach متعددة لرؤية كيف يتصرف اللف المغزلي في سيناريوهات
مختلفة إليكم واحدة لنرسل الذرات عبر جهاز واحد لفصل الحزمة إلى اثنتين تقابلان
حزمة لف مغزلي لأعلى وحزمة لف مغزلي لأسفل ثم نرسل كل حزمة عبر جهاز
منفصل خاص بها مع Qiskit الـ circuit الكمية المقابلة لهذه التجربة تشبه الأخيرة لكن مع قياسين
بدلاً من واحد هنا استبدلنا الدورانات العشوائية التي حاكت تأثير الفرن بـ
gate تُسمى Hadamard لأن تطبيق Hadamard سيعطينا نفس احتمالات القياس التي أعطاها الفرن
لكنها أبسط بكثير في الاستخدام فنقيس مرة ثم مرة ثانية و
المدرج التكراري الناتج للتجربة يبدو هكذا حيث سلاسل البتات على محور X تقابل
نتائج القياسين إذا قيس الـ qubit صفراً في المرتين فهذا يقابل سلسلة بتات 0 0 أو إذا
قيس أولاً صفراً ثم واحداً فهذا يقابل 1 0 وهكذا يبدو أنه إذا قيس لف مغزلي لأعلى في
التجربة الأولى سيكون لف مغزلي لأعلى في الثانية ونفس الشيء مع ذرات اللف المغزلي لأسفل هذا يعني أنه في التجربة الأولى
كان هناك احتمال متساوٍ لقياس لأعلى أو لأسفل لكن بحلول التجربة الثانية كانت النتيجة محددة بالفعل فالشاشتان
في نهاية كل جهاز Stern-Gerlach ثانٍ سيكون لكل منهما بقعة واحدة فقط شاشة بها
كل ذرات اللف المغزلي لأعلى وشاشة بها كل ذرات اللف المغزلي لأسفل لتجربتنا التالية لنبدأ
بحزمة من ذرات لف مغزلي لأعلى فقط مع تجربة Stern-Gerlach فيزيائية حقيقية يمكنكم فعل ذلك بإرسالها
عبر جهاز Stern-Gerlach وحجب الحزمة المنحرفة لأسفل فجميع الذرات المنحرفة لأعلى تكون
لف مغزلي لأعلى الآن لنرسل هذه الحزمة عبر جهاز Stern-Gerlach آخر لكن هذه المرة لندير المغانط 90 درجة بحيث
أن تدرج الحقل سيحرف الذرات المسافرة بهذا الاتجاه لليسار أو لليمين بدلاً من ذلك هل سنرى
بقعة واحدة أم اثنتين أم شيئاً مختلفاً تماماً لهذه التجربة
سنشغل الـ circuit التالية على Qiskit نبدأ بحالة الصفر لأن حزمة الذرات في هذه التجربة كلها
لف مغزلي لأعلى ثم gate الـ Hadamard هذه تتبادل إحداثيي X و Z بحيث يكون لها تأثير تدوير
جهاز Stern-Gerlach فالآن نقيس إسقاط اللف المغزلي لليسار أو لليمين بدلاً من لأعلى أو لأسفل هنا نحصل على
مدرج تكراري للقياسات يبدو هكذا فنرى أن اللف المغزلي على محور X أيضاً لا يأخذ إلا قيمتين
يمكننا تسميتهما لف مغزلي لليسار ولف مغزلي لليمين فهذه التجربة تُظهر أنه إذا قستم إسقاط X للف مغزلي
قيس سابقاً ليكون لف مغزلي لأعلى على Z سيكون لف مغزلي لليسار أو لليمين باحتمال متساوٍ لنقارن
هذا مرة أخيرة بالتوقع الكلاسيكي فقط لتسليط الضوء على الفرق كلاسيكياً تذكروا أنني
قلت أنه إذا كان المغناطيس القضيبي الذري الصغير يشير عمودياً على تدرج الحقل المغناطيسي للجهاز
القوة على تلك الذرة يجب أن تكون صفراً لا يجب أن تنحرف لأعلى أو لأسفل في تلك الحالة سنرى بقعة واحدة في
منتصف الشاشة بدلاً من ذلك نرى بقعتين فنصف الذرات لها لف مغزلي لليسار ونصفها لليمين رغم
أنها قيست سابقاً لتكون لأعلى فمن منظور ميكانيكا الكم بينما قد يكون مغرياً
مساواة اللف المغزلي لأعلى بمتجه يشير لأعلى واللف المغزلي لأسفل بمتجه يشير لأسفل الأمر ليس بهذه البساطة كما نرى
من التجربة الأخيرة لفهم ما يحدث فعلاً هنا نحتاج للتعمق أكثر في مواضيع
التراكب والقياس الكمي وهذا سيكون فيديو ليوم آخر كما بقيت لدينا أسئلة أكثر
حول كيف تعمل ميكانيكا الكم بالضبط كذلك كان الحال مع Stern و Gerlach تجربتهما لم تفسر
كل شيء لكنها قطعت شوطاً طويلاً في ترسيخ ميكانيكا الكم كضرورة لفهم العالم
الطبيعي كانت واحدة من أهم التجارب التأسيسية في ميكانيكا الكم التي أثبتت تكميم
الزخم وقدمت دليلاً على خاصية أساسية جديدة للطبيعة تُسمى اللف المغزلي للتصارع مع
وفهم قواعد العالم الكمي اضطر فيزيائيون مثل Stern و Gerlach لتشمير سواعدهم وتصميم
تجارب ووضع تنبؤات وأحياناً الخطأ فعلاً لا بديل عن تجربة الأشياء بأنفسكم
فإذا أردتم تجربة إجراء بعض التجارب الكمية الحقيقية توجهوا إلى وحدة Stern-Gerlach
المرتبطة في الوصف شكراً للمشاهدة وأراكم في المرة القادمة